today on how they do it if you watch my
youtube channel there's a good chance
you've already seen Tom Scott's video
this video has X amount of views if not
check it out
but basically what he does is run a
background job that hits the YouTube API
to update the title with the latest view
count every few minutes then another
youtuber you may have heard of mr. beast
appears to be doing the same thing in
his latest video where the thumbnail
updates every few minutes with the
amount of money given away if you're
wondering how to do this you might be a
little disappointed when Tom Scott says
I'm not gonna talk about the exact
details of my code here it is not the
important part because code is just
incredibly dull on camera but I have to
disagree there because in my opinion if
the code is the most exciting part so in
today's video we'll take a deep dive
into api's and i'll show you exactly how
these youtubers are updating their
videos automatically in the background
if you're new here like and subscribe
and you can grab the full source code
from github my primary mission today is
to teach you everything you need to know
about api's which is an essential skill
for both front-end and back-end
developers along the way you'll learn
about API authentication and oaah
- how to work with Google API s and
nodejs and how to schedule your code to
run in the background with a service
cloud function but first let's answer
the question what is an API an
application programming interface is
simply a way for two pieces of software
to talk to each other in this demo we
have our application which will
eventually live on a cloud function it
needs to talk to YouTube to get the view
count for a video and then tell YouTube
to update the video with a new title to
facilitate this YouTube has a standard
set of functions where developers can
request the data they need on the web
api's are accessed over HTTP or in other
words there's a URL on the internet that
connects that server to the rest of the
Internet the most popular standard for
implementing API is in today's world is
rest which stands for representational
state transfer API is that implement the
standard like YouTube are called restful
api is the most important concept to
understand is that restful api s are
stateless which means the client and the
server don't need to know anything about
each other's internal state instead they
simply pass messages back and forth the
process starts when the client your
application makes a request an HTTP
request message has a very specific form
at the start line contains the URL of
the API you're making a request to it
also contains an HTTP method for verb
that defines what you're trying to do on
the server a get request means you're
trying to access data but not modify it
where is a post request
means you're trying to create some new
data on the server the reason this is
important is because the API can design
endpoints based on a specific entity we
can see that in the YouTube API where it
has different entities for comments
videos playlists etc the cool thing
about YouTube is that it has an API
Explorer so we can actually look at the
raw HTTP message for example to retrieve
a list of videos we point to this videos
endpoint as a get request then if we
wanted to update that video we'd point
to the same URL but instead make it a
put request so the takeaway here is that
the URL defines the resource or entity
that lives there and the verb defines
what you want to do to that entity now
back in the HTTP message after the start
line we have headers the headers contain
additional metadata about the request
for example the accept header tells the
server which type of content that the
client will accept back which more often
than not will be JSON the headers also
handle things like authorization to
determine if the user making the request
is authorized to do so then after the
headers we have the body which is
typically in JSON format and it contains
a payload of data that the server can
use to update something or create a new
record on the server okay so now that we
have our request message that message
gets sent to the server or API it
receives the request and then executes
whatever code needs to be done to handle
it like reading or writing to a database
for example when it's done it formats an
HTTP response message to go back to the
client it also has a very specific
format with a start line that contains
the status code there are a bunch of
different status codes and they're used
to tell the client what happened to
their request if everything worked then
you should get a 200 status code which
means okay codes at the 200 level means
success codes at the 400 level mean that
you did something wrong and codes at the
500 level mean the server failed for
some reason and then below that we also
have a body which contains the actual
content that the server is sending back
down to the client which is often JSON
data or HTML to use in a front-end
application and that's really all there
is to it it's a simple request response
exchange of data between two pieces of
software that live on the internet now
that you know how API is work let's
build a background job that runs every
few minutes to grab the latest viewcount
from YouTube and then update a YouTube
videos title first we need a piece of
software to make API calls from to
handle that I'll be using a firebase
cloud function with the nodejs runtime
if you're not a firebase user already
it's better
easy to set up install the firebase
command-line tools run firebase in it
and you now have a service environment
to start writing your code in now
YouTube of course is a Google product
which means you need to enable the API
from the Google cloud platform console
most major API is out there Google
included provides software developer
kits to work with their API in our
nodejs project we can install the Google
API SPAC egde with NPM what the SDK does
is simplify the process of making calls
to the API if you wanted to you could
send raw HTTP request to Google and in
theory that would work fine but that
would be doing things the hard way when
using the SDK we can import Google into
our code and now we have intellisense
for not just YouTube but any Google API
like if we take a look at Google Drive
for example you can see it gives us a
variety of different end points and then
we can simply call a method and the
Google SDK will format the HTTP request
for us so that's awesome but at this
point we need to schedule a background
job to run our code every few minutes in
cloud functions we can do that by first
setting up an export with the name of
the function and then we call functions
pub/sub schedule and pass in a cron
schedule as the argument this translates
to run every three minutes or in
firebase we have a more readable option
of just writing every three minutes
after that we'll add a callback function
that will run every three minutes after
we deploy this function to the cloud now
inside this function will create a
variable name to YouTube but in order to
use the YouTube API we need to
authenticate so let's take a second to
talk about API authentication there are
two main types of authentication that
you should know about right now API keys
and o'a when thinking about YouTube or
any API for that matter there are two
main types of resources nose that are
public and those that are private for
example a get request to a public video
is something that anybody can do but if
we wanted to modify that video with a
put request we would need to have the
proper authorization to do so like being
the videos owner or being an admin at
YouTube or as developers we could get
the users permission using OAuth so
here's what that boils down to if we
only need to read public resources then
we can use our YouTube developer API key
the API key is simply a way for YouTube
to identify who is making the request
which is important because it's a free
API that has a quota on usage which
means that a given API key can only make
so many requests per day in the case of
YouTube they assigned
points to every request and then cap
your daily usage at 10,000 points now
because we're updating an actual video
we need to go through OAuth 2 in this
case I'm not going to go through the
entire process in this video because it
can be somewhat complicated but if it's
something that you're interested in
implementing I have a video for that on
fire ship IO basically what needs to
happen is you need to generate a URL
where the user can log in to their
YouTube or Google account and your app
will request permission to perform
actions on the user's behalf these
permissions are known as scopes when the
user says ok Google will redirect them
back to your site with an authorization
code you then send that code to your
server or cloud function and use it to
create an access token and refresh token
these values can be saved to a database
so you can make API calls for the user
in the future when you're ready to make
an API call you can read the tokens from
your database and create this oo-oo to
client object and then you use it as the
auth argument now that we're
authenticated we can make an HTTP
request to the API using the Google API
is SDK we call a youtube videos list
with the video ID and then we specify
the data that we want back in our case
we want the statistics which will
include the view count and also the
snippet which contains the raw data
about the video like the description
title and so on the API responds back
with JSON which is automatically
converted into a JavaScript object for
us and the actual data about this video
is the first element in the items array
from there we'll grab the view count
then interpolate it into a string to
format the new title and now we're ready
to update our video we'll call YouTube
videos update and then we'll define a
request body remember the body is the
data that the API will use to make the
update we'll assign it the new title and
then it also requires a category ID
which we can keep from the original
snippet and that's all there is to it
now we just need to deploy our code to
get it running in production open up the
command line and run firebase deploy
this will deploy your code as a service
function in the cloud you'll see your
function in the firebase console if your
function doesn't seem to be working you
can check out the logs for errors I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want access to more
advanced content consider becoming a CRO
member at fire ship IO
thanks for watching and I will see
the next one
[Music]